I What is the other option? >> he's genius. >> This
guy This guy is so smart. You're sitting here like I have the
moral high ground against Destiny. Yep. >> Jeffrey Epstein
has the moral high No, not quite.
>> You know what's great? I actually just don't believe
you.
>> Anybody Just be the whole chugay. Just yell and scream
and just cry. Just kind of write down cry.
>> Uh did you think that
>> Gilded Poo made a video on you and then deleted it a
few hours later? Oh, wait. Do we get a Do we get an archive?
I would watch that right now.
Oh, do I have [clears throat] a little treat for you?
>> Here you go. It's awesome. It's awesome.
Destiny promotes deplatforming a 28-minute video. >> a
six It's a premiere archive. So there's like the six-minute pre-up.
You got Oh, right at the beginning. Okay, okay. It's a 22-minute
video. >> Apparently he deleted this video shortly after
publishing it. I'm not exactly sure why. There's a couple things
I want you to know going into this video. First off, okay, some
of the stuff this guy says in this video about what should be
right and wrong and what he should be upset about is insane considering
he has a kid that I'm assuming he lives with, that he cares for.
the second thing is
I might have forgotten the second thing.
All right, let's check this out. >> claims like doxxing
or other claims that I've seen going around like what? Organized
harassment and some other stuff. I've not seen sufficient evidence
for that. There's also claims that Nick Andrews, for example,
has lied multiple times about the contents of what he said in
this Stark server.
Oh, but you know what happened here, right? I'm already I'm already
wise to Dan basically said, "Hey Star Dust, do you know some
people you could get this out to?" She probably went to him,
Gilded Poo here with like the whole narrative she was going to
spin.
And this [__] probably just went with it one-to-one
without really checking any of it. I feel like that's 100% what
happened here. Also, to be clear, I don't know definitively if
she did edit this. I know she is his editor, so I'm assuming,
but I you know, to be clear, I don't know 100% if that's >> have
to fire her starters cuz he couldn't afford to pay her? Was that
what happened?
Uh maybe. I'm not sure. Uh I've not actually looked into that
any further. I don't know if he actually lied or not. And personally,
I don't really care because again, there hasn't been substantial
evidence to prove much of anything on either side. For the most
part, it's It's literally just fully it like dude, that's that's
actually crazy. Somebody sent me a collage of like his logs.
And yes, this is like a thing he's doing where he's like posted
a bunch of stuff.
That's what he puts in the video. Okay. All right, all right,
all right. Cool, cool, cool. But like, it's not just that. He's
literally said on his stream like live. Yeah, I do dox people.
Yeah, I am going to dox people. Yeah, of course I do. Of course
I do. Like it's not
It's so crazy to just start off with no, there's no evidence
to this. >> It's just been a series of a series of narratives
with very little citing of evidence thus far. So, with that said,
These are all of the people against us, by the way. It's just
the dumbest
redneck trailer trash loser people. Just absolute scum of the
earth. Just totally
who are actually trying to fight us on this. It's so crazy to
watch.
I'm not here to go after them. Now, at the same time, people
might be thinking, "Are you going to defend Destiny?"
I'm not going to defend Destiny. Destiny has done several unhinged
things throughout this drama, such as calling to have people
doxxed, trying to get people demonetized and deplatformed
for This is particularly funny thing. I honestly forgot this.
I By the way, I got a strike for this on Kick. I literally got
a strike for this directly on Kick when he called the report
me.
Okay, snarking. All Quimbee can do is sit there and spam racial
slurs at me or whatever and and complain. Which by the way, you
should >> spam report the [__] out of Kick
streams or whatever the [__] else. The fact that
I'm sitting there with on in Chudlogic's stream and I think Quimbee
called me a on stream. I think he literally was calling [laughter]
me just like spamming racial slurs and [__] at me
because by the way, all these guys in the background of their
channels are
>> Now, if you guys could believe it, these guys also use
racial slurs in private, too. It's their Discord all the time.
They ain't just doing it in public,
if you can believe it. >> Always spam reporting all of
my and coordinating spam reporting all of my 100%. Oh, by the
way, we didn't even spam report all of this [__]
It was like I I just only had this stuff for YouTube. That was
it. I didn't go after Kick cuz I was like I I don't even know
if Kick goes back and looks. It wasn't worth it, so. In the clip,
I actually go harder. I say that I'm going to do more than we
actually Like I say we, me and my mods. Again, nobody I put this
like a link to this stuff in the in the Discord or whatever,
but I this is all me. If anybody recalls, I did a debate not
that long ago with Stale 2000, where Stale 2000 was arguing in
favor
of mass flagging.
I of course am against it, but on top of
I'm against reporting in general. I think snitching is cowardly
and gay.
Some of us don't want to Dude, this guy Send this guy to Jacksonville,
too, to the drill rap scene, okay? You guys want to just escalate
infinitely till somebody gets killed? You. Get the [__]
out of here. No, there's a established set of rules and all of
us want to play by those rules cuz those rules lead to the best
content. When you have chilling effects on on menacing people
in real life like evoking the idea of real life harm against
them, when there's a chilling effect against that, you get the
best speech, you get the most like some combination of free speech
and control at the same time. You shouldn't You shouldn't dox
people, you shouldn't invoke or or menace real world harm.
Obviously, okay? Unless somebody is posting like I don't know,
child
or some sort of like almost universally illegal material on a
platform, there is absolutely no reason to report let alone mass
flag. And doing so against people that you're in drama with just
looks really gay because it is. And Destiny has done that from
these screenshots I have seen. The reason I'm bringing all this
up
Why is he screaming LIKE THIS? >> THE REASON I'M SAYING
all of this is because you see
it would be one thing if it was [snorts] just Destiny
versus a bunch of starkers. That would
expected. It's expected that Destiny is going to do stupid unhinged
Okay? And the worst part about Destiny is he probably just own
it and say yeah, I'm being petty [__] them, right?
So yeah, that's expected. It's Just sit back and go it's okay.
Why why do why are you guys making a fuss? Just sit back, just
lay back and go shut up. Shut stop complaining. expected that
the starkers would go after Destiny for this. It's this is all
Here's the problem though, is I had to retweet stale2000
because he was kind of correct about something and that is that
a lot of these content creators, the ones that have complained
about Destiny doing this
are secretly in favor his
mass flagging is based actually take.
What do I mean by that?
Well, here's Justil.
I'm pretty sure I literally said at the time when he got demonetized,
I said, "I think this guy should be demonetized and probably
banned, but not for this." And so it probably shouldn't happen
here. I'm pretty sure I said that publicly. The idea that this
is a private stance is like beyond the
Yeah, I told I told this story that yeah, oh, I didn't even think
to point that out, but I told the exact story that we had like
an argument about this and I'm like, "You're right, probably
shouldn't uh probably shouldn't be called the Charlie Kirk demonetization
cuz I don't want that done to me. I know that I know that, but
obviously I as I've never once hidden ever. I don't like Destiny.
I don't like this guy. So.
I was just I was happy that he was getting with the same way
he tries to with other people a little bit. Um but but but you're
saying in that Discord they're saying, "Hey, this guy sucks.
Let's all go mass report his ass." Maybe yeah. If we'll hear
about this. Include all the time I was like pausing here.
I was in trouble when I talked about >> is telling. Cuz
I know the second I actually talk about this
I'm going to be greenlit to be reported by everybody's community
every stream I do for the next 3 years.
That's That's why there's a pregnant
Cuz I know that whatever harassment they were doing, whatever
it was, by the way, which I wasn't reporting him for.
Uh like any attempts at doxxing, anything any of the [__]
that happens, okay? I knew it was going to go to 10x the second
I talked about this. And so I was trying to avoid He keeps going.
For clarity, Destiny is accusing
the people in the snark server that Justil was a part of of organizing
mass flagging campaigns. And we get three hums
and silence.
I'll be honest.
I'll be honest >> remember this ever happening outside
of >> I you forgot. >> one instance.
I And there might be more. Like, sorry, more individual. But
there's only one time I've ever advocated for reporting somebody.
It's Destiny.
And it's for what he's done to me. Right? It's for his targeted
harassment, his targeted doxing attempts, his attempts to dox
people in my Discord,
Do you have any idea how incredibly
that's up? I What is the other option He's genius. This guy This
guy is so
That is so
and so gay. Why doesn't he call it? >> is Wait. Wait. This
guy is really brave. Why doesn't he call it? Uh yeah, he's not
at all. He'll definitely call it, for sure.
Like, honestly
this is one of those people that's so stupid, I just
Somebody messaged me who was just like, this guy literally like
Basically, it's just child Like, unless you're posting child
directly to YouTube, he thinks reporting is wrong no matter what.
And honestly
I'm not even positive on that one, to be honest with you, based
on some of the other [__] he talks about. What is
wrong with you? >> OH MY GOD! >> That's That's an
explosion you're causing. As far as I know, this guy only
and not any child
It's only There's only intuition. I have no clear-cut evidence
that this guy is a It is just every intuition I have. >> admitted
to having a hard drive full of
He's admitted that. >> he admitted to having a hard drive
full play. Jay Stalk, did you not know this? The zo sadist stuff?
I knew the zo sadist stuff. So, he had a hard drive full of uh
and he'd like spam in Discords uh to troll them. And then people
got upset at this, and then his response is uh for like redemption,
uh he films himself like showing the hard drive, he puts it on
like something, and then he shoots at it. And he's like, "Look,
I'm done. I'm
Dude. So, it's epic. It's epic.
Uh to be fair, that does sound like kind of funny, but
>> I was being harassed. Oh, dude, why? Why?
I'm so happy they blew us up because I don't think a lot of people
know about the Peace Go clip. >> Bringing up like other
examples of like doxing like you or >> At this point actually
I just I don't care what happens to any of these communities.
Like Peace Go's included. I think that all you guys are weird
and need to be wiped from the internet. I think it's all like
gotten way Oh, look at this toady.
Just smiling. Oh, yeah, get rid of Peace Go, too. Haha.
>> out of hand. I'm like at this point I don't give a [__]
about any of it. Tremble as Hey Spider, are you >> gotten
way too comfortable talking [__] and being weird
and talking harassing
So, it's kind of weird.
It probably gives uh J Soc and his community more ammo, no? A
little bit. Really? I thought a few people left the server once
people started getting doxxed. That's what I saw. And now I I
put up the segment today where I can put that up and walk through
like how Destiny's talking about talking about doxing, talk about
why he's doxing and who he's doxxed, and how he says these communities
all need to be wiped off the internet, Peace Go's included. So,
I didn't have that out. I don't think it was as widespread, but
now it's attached to this and I can get that message out to more
people that Destiny was basically threatening Peace Go's community,
as well.
He's made.
And again, >> has said explicitly like, you know, I
harass, report everything to just get rid of you. So, it's like
if he's doing things in that process that are not just TOS, but
actively harmful, what is the argument against reporting him?
There's
Like and just to hurt like communities. Like he There's a clip
where he's talking about this and he's literally like gleeful
when he's like he says like, "Well, I thought I thought a bunch
of people left that community since I started doxing people there."
It's like, dude, I What else am I supposed to say? You're trying
to hurt somebody else's channel, somebody else's community by
by people out of that community.
And you're doing it directly yourself.
Like you're sitting here like I have the moral high ground against
Destiny and
>> Jeffrey Epstein has the moral high No, not quite.
>> I had to just shout for a second, but It's close now.
>> do. Most people do. [laughter] You're going to sit here
and just straight up admit you were organizing a mass flagging
campaign. Good way to thermonuclear blast your own moral high
Huh. Why did he delete the video?
Dude, this is so stupid. >> To be very clear, let me let
me explain real quick my stance on flagging and
Um again, this is just to reiterate. I don't care if somebody
doxes me. I don't care if somebody swats me. I don't give a almighty
if they threaten to come come to my home. Out of those three
things I listed, two of those things have
And you know what's really amazing about that? I didn't Why is
your's my problem? Why is the fact that you don't care if you
get killed or >> either doxxed or swatted. He doesn't care
that it happens and he has a kid. Swattings and doxxings are
things that can and have been shown to like lead to real world
harm.
and he expects us all to live by his standard. That's all it
is. It's not like if this was just a thing where it was harming
himself, sure, who cares? But like he's caring for a kid. Like
this is deranged when you're like a father caring for a child,
is it not? I I mean, you could just say you don't report no matter
what, but then how do you stop people from doing this to you?
The only way you do that is by basically engaging in the same
tactics.
It's So, I I don't know. Or or escalating past that, right? He
literally he literally is not even attempting to make any kind
of argument. He's just like, you know, knows he wants to go after
you, so he's just made a video on it. I just let yourself get
Why? Yep, just lay down and die. Just you lay down and die? Just
lay down Just lay down and die for me.
them. I did not ask people to report them and I didn't even block
them because it's cowardly and it's made and it's cringe. Why
on earth would you do that? It's so
And beyond that point
to make this even Beyond the point that you're gay cuz I don't
like you. Further from that point >> more clear. This violates
like the number one rule of getting doxxed. You shut the [__]
up and you don't [__] acknowledge it. What do you
think flagging it down does? Oh yeah, it tells them they were
right.
I didn't flag him when he attempted to dox me. So so just keep
letting him dox more and more people and never do anything about
it then. That's That's really smart, actually. When When I was
the only person, I did not flag this guy at all.
I was the only person Well, when I was one of a very small handful
of people targeted, which was only a little while, I didn't flag
this guy. It was when he went after my community explicitly for
it. >> is it? You got to go on stream, man. I actually
can't deal with this guilded poop. Loser hiding like a all the
time,
It's very sad. It's very sad.
And if you flag Destiny down after he is he is doxxed you and
you've gotten rid of all of his platforms like you appear to
have wanted
what do you think happens then? You think the harassment stops?
You think it just comes to an end?
No, I just don't want him to make money for it. That's basically
it.
I I understand that he's a totally deranged psycho and he's going
to keep doing whatever he's going to do for as long as he can
possibly do it. I just don't want him to make money while doing
it. While trying to like actively destroy people I enjoy watching.
>> just like, you know, let's say let's say he loses YouTube
and he's really good at just a gig. Well, maybe he would you
know, not want to throw that away.
Possibly. Yeah.
After you've cu- Like the TOS is your legal code and your legal
system, right? >> Because what's his what's his other option?
His other option is setting up his own CDN and streaming directly
on D D J. That's his other option and then he has no uh I mean
like I don't I don't think I don't think you get paid from uh
from posting on Rumble. And he's got it all Oh wait. Oh wait.
No, I forgot he over the CEO of Rumble. >> Oh yes, [laughter]
dude. Oh yeah. So he wouldn't be getting paid. He might be able
to stream there, but he he wouldn't be getting paid. I forgot
the Rumble CEO hates him. >> Confirmed that the doxing
information was correct.
Are you insane?
Do you not understand how crazy people work? Dude, I'm I feel
like I'm so as a content creator. I can't be 1 1,000th this confident
without knowing the facts. Like that the clip he's reacting >> as
well and like yeah, I bet this guy will let you just get on just
say the you've ever heard. It's like wow, you like actually think
that. You're like the dumbest
Uh it's so Yeah. I I have like such a high bar for when I want
to take a strong position. Like such that I sometimes won't take
a strong position on something when it's like good to do it for
content. Because I've like I haven't looked into this enough.
I just I can't do it. I can't put myself out there like that.
And then there's like this who haven't thought about it at all
and they're just like yeah. Hey, you're gay if you don't agree
with me.
But can make no mistake. Make no mistake, Destiny's crazy. What
do you What do you think Destiny's going to do
in the wake of that? Have you thought at all through any of this?
So I also that's pretty much precisely why I wasn't doing it
publicly at all. So no, this is really stupid. This is really
dumb. And my take on this is so black and >> out about
you on Twitter.
Yeah, I know. I I asked him at some point. I was like hey, what's
your actual problem? I think I I even remember what he said.
I covered it earlier today. I can't He's so forgettable. I cannot
remember what he said at all. I don't even want people flagging
people on my behalf. So, yeah. Anyway. So, I will cop to that.
That I absolutely
It would have been I don't remember what it was. But, I will
cop to Yeah, I totally tried to report Destiny for what he's
done to me and people around me. Is there somebody we've mass
reported? Is there somebody Well, I don't even remember what
I said in that server. But, I definitely
around the time of like the e-sports Battle and Wicked Supreme
stuff. Yeah, it was like, "Okay, the we're we're mass we're reporting
this guy. This loser." mentioned on stream before. I've kind
of tried to go out of my way never to mention it on stream cuz
Yeah, I wonder why. a total psycho who already has a vendetta.
I don't want to incur like more of a vendetta. I don't even know
what that looks like at this point. BUT,
I don't want to get mass reporting back.
It's It's It's almost like that's the consequence of mass reporting
people in the first place. Sorry. He's confused.
Destiny deserves it and you don't. I mean, obviously, but
I don't know. Like, there's there's a big difference between
just mass reporting someone you don't like and then mass reporting
someone who's causing like actual tangible harm. Yeah, this is
so obviously the argument is obvious. There is an active harm
being
It's a serious active harm and it's against YouTube TOS.
it should be reported.
That I thought The argument is literally that simple. What is
the argument against J Stokes who's causing an active
serious harm?
That's the consequence of mass reporting people. It's almost
like this is kind of what happens whenever you go full and start
mass reporting people. Like, I don't want I don't I don't want
to to I don't want to shoot this person. I don't want to shoot
at this person because they might shoot at me back.
Because they will mass report with
You see somebody in alley and they're like someone. You've got
a gun. You're like, "Hey, stop." And
apparently it's not like >> is bad. Don't don't say anything.
Just walk in. >> Why would you try to stop this from happening?
He might shoot back at you. Are you shocked that he'd shoot back
at
With no actual impetus. It was when he used his his platform,
DGG, right? The destiny.gg website. In other words, they bad,
us good. Yes, yes, we got it. Yeah.
Uh very technically. I will say I also reference this cuz I was
watching this and I was like kind of like, uh Should I talk about
what he's talking about? Cuz I know I know what he's upset about
right now. I was like, "Should I talk about it?" I'm like, "Yeah,
I don't I don't mind making this public." Like they're going
to make it public and try to make a big story out of it. I'll
just explain what happened cuz I'm totally justified in calling
for this. And but what I should do is I what I tried to do today
was put it together a little bit more, like precisely what it
was about.
Pretty rough. Dox multiple people in my community. That site
is linked to his YouTube. When you have a site where you're engaging
in TOS activity, right? And And sorry, in against community guidelines
activity, there's a policy that says if you link to that on your
YouTube page and you engage in TOS breaking policies over there
or TOS breaking behaviors over there, you can be banned. So,
not only were they trying to report Destiny for doxxing, but
it wasn't even doxxing on the platform that they were reporting
the [__] for. No, he was just calling for people's
deaths on on the platform. Oh, yeah, he was also Yeah. And the
the the people he was doxxing specifically. He was, yeah, he
was. They were go using some very specific verbage in the TOS
to justify.
This is so >> verbage. The verbage right says, uh you can't
link to TOS breaking content. Well, that's really specific, bro.
Yep. Yep. Mate, bro. Like what the [__] right? Like
it's just gay. This is gay. What is wrong with you? Like I can't
imagine hating some
Again, this is a 40-year-old man who cannot form a actual argument.
It's >> No coherent thought. Like, and it's like so obvious
cuz if he if he thinks you can report child porn on YouTube,
if somebody had a really popular YouTube page and they linked
directly to a site with child porn on it, you think they should
just be allowed to stay on the platform? You're just like, "Yeah,
keep that guy there." Still on the platform. Still on the platform.
Okay, bro. >> platform. Somebody so much that I'm fishing
around through the TOS desperately trying to find something to
go after Uh by the way, uh for about 6 months, people were desperately
linking me this TOS page going, "Report this guy. Report this
guy. Report this guy. Report this guy. Report this guy. Report
this guy. Right now, report this guy." I was like, "Uh
kind of he's kind of not doing it anymore and I like I I'm super
against
It was specifically and I say the problem is at the beginning
of this clip I say, "Oh, for things he's done to me." It's really
and this is just fully born out in the logs is because of him
going after Esports Batman and threatening Peace Go. for them
for >> it's like, you know,
it's one thing
yeah, to get doc streams on you, but you can you can keep going
with doc streams on you, you know? Like, it's not it's not the
end of the world. If someone's going to literally try to just
ruin your community by doing harm to people within your community
so that people are chilled from from every interaction with your
And yeah, I'm sorry. That's like literally this is like, you
know, I don't know what What what would they call that? There's
like some uh is it if it was like a lawsuit, it would be like
tortious interference or something like that, right? You're like
deliberately maliciously
interfering with someone's business in a way that isn't um allowed
in the market. So, Yep. Yep. Yep. It's like
yeah, but It's like not even remotely close to like something
that's objectionable. And everybody understands that. I really
can't that black hat person I'll I'll I'll up the tweet and then
I'll Dude, you know what? Dude, Destiny says that if someone
slashes your tires on the way to work, you can shoot them. Destiny's
slashing your tires. You're You're only reporting him. So, this
seems perfectly within Destiny's I mean
not only that but I'll just point out once again, he had it already
on stream, but one second second one second one second. He He
already had it Guild of Pooh already had it on stream, but if
anyone can find J Star calling me an F slur on his Kick stream,
send me the clip and I will report him to the Kick Partner Program
as well.
I got a strike for this by the way on
Like he's just straight up in his chat doing the same thing.
I'm going to report this guy. We should report this guy. But
like honestly just to begin with, he's already somebody who does
this, but again, didn't even didn't even try to go back at him
for it.
You know, we do we do take the uh
slings and arrows sometimes.
But that's cuz he was doxxing members of my community just for
having normal conversations.
Just for having normal
>> Just for having normal conversations.
Yes. You know what's great? I actually just don't believe you.
>> Anybody who ever That's That's like whenever a cop
Awesome video. I Dude, I wish I wish I wish I was joking. I wish
he wasn't this like totally unstable and like losing his
I'm not even joking. Like I wish this was not the case. Maybe
we had a couple beers. Like that that's what that was. Um so
no, I I I don't take it on face value. W W alcoholism analogy?
Do you what you just said? Now granted I am not saying for the
record that he or any of the members of his community deserve
to be doxxed. Obviously not. Obviously
that is astronomically
unhinged for Destiny to do. Okay?
That is absolutely [__] >> word instead of
just saying something's wrong or bad. It's always like oh, that's
unhinged. That's deranged. That's >> Well, because let's
try with with a lot of people like Diorio, I can tell that doing
it deliberately. This guy literally has not formed an argument.
He doesn't have an actual opinion on this. He is a dented idiot.
And he could never defend any of this in any conversation cuz
he's just a [__] the logs he posted. So, this isn't
like directly when he did it. This is like a couple days before
he started doxxing people in the Discord. These are the logs.
I would say repeated unwanted contact or harassment is some kind
of like showing some of it. By the way,
but it's certainly still a form of harassment. I'm sure they're
talking about the cyber stuff. At the end of the day, Cyper is
still basically the only person I'm aware of that has done anything
at all on behalf of Rose's well-being. If all he sent was a single
email to those people with that concern in mind, I don't think
it qualifies as harassment. But like you said, highly inappropriate
IMO. He shouldn't have done it. By the way, this is what Destiny
says is cheering Cyper on. That was the reasoning he used. This
is cheering Cyper on. Like, I don't think it qualifies as harassment,
but like you said, highly inappropriate.
Is apparently the everybody's cheering where a whole bunch of
people are
are basically arguing this stuff and a bunch of them are basically
totally against Cyper contacting at all in the first place.
All all subject to some reasonableness standard. I don't think
cold emailing someone and their family is enough to constitute
harassment. Now, if they told that told him to stop and he continued
to do so, then we're talking.
It's engaging in a course of uninvited unwanted conduct that
would be annoying or alarming. It does not have a legitimate
purpose as well or well-rounded definition. But that's not necessarily
kind of against anything else. It doesn't have to be repeated
to be harassment. Your first message to someone can be harassment
if it's a part of a greater campaign. That's why I chose the
word perpetuating.
The guy to This is what he's crashing out about. Also, That was
tough really.
Destiny's like fighting directly with Cyper on Twitter today.
I saw that earlier, yeah. >> Cyper was like I think Cyper
is like kind of owning him, too, which is very funny. I saw Cyper's
tweet is like, he unblocked me to tweet this and then reblocked
me. So, I'm just I'm just going to point out how this is wrong.
Dude, all these people out here just making enemies out of autism.
I don't I don't know why you do it, dude. Like these people can
be these people can be annoying to you way longer than
way longer than you'd expect if you just lash out at them and
attack them. You got to stop. Destiny and Dan. However,
however, the response is to either say nothing,
which is probably the best option,
Um or if you just can't keep your mouth shut, point and laugh.
But what you don't do is
that. So, all you've done is just told everybody who got or told
the person that did the doxing that every single person they
doxed, they were absolutely correct about. You just went out
there >> how that works.
Dude, this guy is so stupid. That's That's true when it's an
individual instance and you're the one being doxed and you talk
about it in a way that confirms it. That's not true when he's
doxed a broad swathe of people
and you don't necessarily even know that they're all accurate,
you know? That That's not That doesn't follow. He's literally
just arguing that he's like psyched that there's a chilling effect
on the discourse.
Yeah, it's it's crazy. I also
the doxing says it's me is from like March and the reporting
is from months and months and months later.
This argument wouldn't This argument wouldn't even work. a dox.
This is
profound levels of idiotic.
that I shouldn't report him for those things or that it would
be bad or if he wants to come out and talk about it at go ahead.
Dude, why is he his hand over his face like he's Oh, he's got
a cigarette. I was going to say, why is he pretending he's thinking?
There ain't nothing going on up there. >> Yeah, I just
explained it. So, what's great is is it gets worse. Oh, this
is the one. Yeah.
It gets worse, somehow. So, here's yet another clip. He's suing,
I think. Uh I think what's going to happen
Someone talks to me is wanting to be called for the people to
come to my home. I still wouldn't report them because that made
and cringe. Okay, dude.
>> No wonder No wonder he's out here so That is like literally
that is an obvious justified instance of reporting at the best
of times.
And you're saying you you still won't do it even for a petty
kid. Okay, well, enjoy being the most man alive, I guess. of
this guy admitting multiple times to doxing all these people.
He makes up that I've had some hand in it or I've done something
back to him or that something like untoward has happened because
of me.
Literally no evidence no literally no evidence of it. He's going
to keep doing it. I don't think it's healthy to have him on these
platforms and to advocate for doxing more people on these platforms.
I do think he should be banned. I think he should be demonetized.
I don't think he should be doing this with like I don't think
he should have a platform where he's making
And now
he's just straight up saying it.
>> saying it. He is just saying that he
to go after Destiny. >> it out.
Guy goes to three blue one brown and he's like, "This guy is
saying that addition is commutative
and transitive? He's just saying it." It's like, "Yes. Yep, he's
just saying true facts about the world. Yep, 100%." >> out
and said it. This is some cringe like uh visual anti
I think this is gay.
Uh it makes me think that all this is all about is simping over
a woman. That is actually the only way any of this makes sense,
by the way, is oh my god, a got revenge.
We must go and fight for her honor.
This is [__] embarrassing, man.
It's interesting because this is a a pattern that's been revealed.
Actually, there's a really funny clip I'll show you here in a
minute that somewhat proves that point. But but yeah, like it's
it's this is all really really really really really
stupid. This is really stupid. This does not make you look good
in any way, shape, or form.
I think that's why you did it was just to look cool. To Yeah,
to look very cool. That's why I you know definitely called for
this type of publicly multiple times. I think that basically
nobody saw this this clip I know I know that she clipped it that
she watched this stream but she didn't post this clip and I didn't
go and what I didn't go to kick or anything like that I I did
it hoping that eventually Destiny would have a mole in that Discord
and that it would come out. there and say well Destiny isn't
good
But Destiny being bad doesn't make you look good. off of this.
It's actually pretty over. Kicks out the exemplars of morality.
I'm pretty sure they're still pretty badly against doxxing. Does
he play video games
Well, he knows he's going to get owned. He's implying that he's
going to sue I guess. Oh [__] I don't No, I I think
probably just going after the platforms is the good choice. I
think I think YouTube given what has already happened to him
on YouTube would consider terminating him over this. Bro. >> 100%
right? I never By the way, don't want anybody to make anything
up. Just want to take the explicit admissions of guilty conduct,
right? And just say yeah, I think I think this YouTube channel
is YouTube. >> Slimy bro. They do I okay. >> May maybe
I've got just like no commentary to add. Just like just say just
saying just saying [__] just so slimy bro. Wait what
what He should just get a soundboard, right? Like if he was hitting
like the fuzz and Fuzz fuzz >> hitting the crashes. Yeah,
way better way better. Great off platform stuff. Good for him.
That was the implication.
It's slimy. Like you can't say this [__] and not
look like a
This looks wow. And I know there's a lot of people defending
him. >> which is coming across almost like an academic
paper, frankly. Basically like Socrates, I think. This guy >> Yeah,
I feel I'm being enlightened right now. around saying, "Oh, no,
he's a >> Oh, I don't know anything. You're gay. You're
good gay.
Okay, why? You want to be dogxed? Okay.
When somebody tries to swat me and my child, I just like I'm
just going to use my kids as meat shield. I'm just going to use
my kids as a meat shield against the
I think something >> TOS and blah blah blah blah blah.
I don't care. I actually just don't give a
Okay? Like, yeah, it's bad. Yeah, Destiny bad. You don't need
a whole lot of to convince me of that. However,
to respond
It's honestly like he doesn't need to be convinced Destiny's
bad. Can I convince you in some way that your child's life is
worth protecting? I'm not sure I could, but I would like to try.
Could we have a talk? Would you come on the stream, Gilded Poo?
I just like to try to convince you that your child's life >> life
is worth protecting. What? What if moving your cursor from one
side of the into the middle, clicking a few buttons, filling
out a text field, clicking another button to try and, you know,
protect your child a little bit? I think so. Maybe that by just
trying to deplatform or trying to mass flag him is just gay.
Um I'm going to assume I'm going to make the assumption that
Nick Andros probably didn't do anything that bad. That Shimo
probably didn't do anything that bad.
He He He agrees with like He agrees with like my perspective,
but like I want to reject it anyway because I know he doesn't
know enough to say that.
Yeah, like I'm just like, dude, I'm going to kind of assume that
it's like, dude, you the facts are there. Just go watch the debate
that happened. >> into it. You Just try to interpret more
than a one piece of information for a video.
It's crazy. Until there's some substantial evidence to prove
otherwise.
He's drunk, right? I don't know if it's really drunk or more
just like uh what would the word be? >> dented. He's just
totally dented. >> Well, he is dented. But like he's a
functional alcoholic. So like I I'm sure this is just his like
baseline. He's probably not drunk. He's probably >> Do
we know this guy's an alcoholic, bro? I'm Wait. >> Uh yeah.
So he is an alcoholic. Do you not Do you remember the story where
he um he got like blackout drunk one day, took a bunch of pictures
of his sent it to a bunch of women, and then woke up?
And then uh when he that um that fat black girl, he said that
the only reason he did that was because uh he had a weekend alone
without his kid, and he wanted to >> get drunk. So he got
blackout drunk
and then completely forgot about it. Aside from that, in a nutshell
though, their justification for that I think is gay. I I think
it's gay. I think it's gay. Visual anti-cringe. And this is it.
Like you're putting in Dan, Dan, let me ask you this. Dan, let
me ask you this. Is Tecto Is Tecto incredibly accused of being
a with a protective order?
Oh, um I think so. Is that true? Okay. So would it be logical
to make sure Tecto isn't violating his order and harassing his
victim?
Now, Dan is going to say this. This is like one of the few things
he said on this stream
uh that wasn't like annoying and gay. Um
but he's going to say something that's absolutely correct. >> This
guy has such well-formed thoughts. That's what I'm noticing here
is this guy really has some well-formed, well-articulated thoughts
that he delivers just perfectly. Everybody I don't like and all
of their actions are gay. It's all gay.
I see where this guy never leaves the
watchful eye of Lylo Convoy and that gaggle of disabled adults.
It's crazy.
No, Shamuel. It's not your business. It's not your It's not your
problem. >> I think every time Go to Poo opens his
I think significantly worse of Beckett. And frankly, I I didn't
know that was
you just needed to take a shot at Beckett, didn't you? You know
Beckett like loves you, right? You know Beckett loves you. >> about
taking shots at Beckett. No, I do I do >> just hit Beckett
in the face. Beckett literally loves you. You're one of his closest
friends. You just punch him in the face so many times every single
day. It's wild to watch. It's the most abusive relationship I've
ever seen. Play nice. Not only is Beckett
a people pleaser,
which is what you're actually describing there. Which is one
of the most despicable things you can be, frankly. As much as
I love Beckett, that is like literally like one of the most annoying
things you can be in in life. Uh is a total people people pleaser,
which Beckett is. He tries to just tell me what I want to hear
when I'm talking to him. He tries to just get out of things and
try to stay out of stuff, which is very lame. Um The fact that
he will play nice with people like this, the fact Anyone that
like has super disabled people like this around them, who have
severe substance abuse issues, just like the horrendous going
on can't take a single thought, and they don't say anything about
it, they don't just rip this person apart, I think incredibly
poorly of them. If If someone's not doing that, I think very
low of them.
I mean,
I understand what you're saying. I don't think rip them apart
I feel like if you're not going to
It needs to be firm. You need to be firm in dealing with them,
right? You can't Like people like this
basically like
they like seek out people like Beckett, who are people pleasers,
who won't give them the the advice or the I guess talking to
or the >> to they need. The the Hey, look, um like every
video you've ever put out is like kind of terrible. And you're
really bad at articulating your thoughts, if you have any going
on in the first place. Who gives a [__] It's a whole
lot of other people's business, a whole lot of other people's
drama. I don't know why you're digging your nose into it. Who
gives a [__]
Oh, and an anti-semite, too. I'll be telling the ADL about that.
Dan Soloman,
>> Hold on, he's not talking He's not talking about Dan.
I do think he's Is he thinking about you or something here? Cuz
he's talking about Shamoo. And Shamoo's shy. Yeah, yeah. Well,
maybe he's just going Maybe it's cuz people call Shamoo Sham
Jew. He's thinking of that. Oh, maybe. Do people call him that?
Okay, awesome.
This is visual anti-simping to the max. Is he trying to say vigilante?
I'm I'm so Vigilante, yeah. Vigilante. If people say it with
an E at the end. You know what I'm saying? Why would you do this?
And then think it makes you look good.
Oh, for you? No. You're not the police. You don't have a PI license.
You're not allowed to be going out and like like looking up people's
and data breaches. So, this If this person You say this was the
only thing Dan said?
That's the most talking Dan said in the entire conversation.
I know. These guys who like sucked off Turkey Tom and Willy Mac
All of the people who do any amount of research. Well, they don't
do the research, but obviously their researchers would use tools
like this, right? Yeah, but it's not even not even that, though.
It's like what Dan's saying like about it being illegal and It's
It's not illegal to to view data breaches in most of the US as
far as I understand, if any of it.
I didn't hear him say it was illegal. I thought he said he's
basically saying you're not allowed to go and look. No, he said
he said it's illegal. You don't have a PI license.
Oh, for you? No. You're not the police. You don't have a PI license.
You're not allowed to be going out and like looking up people's
and data >> So, this If this person is leaking documents
Yeah, I don't think he said illegal. I think he said you're not
allowed. Maybe you could have inferred illegal there or maybe
>> sure that was something previously that pretty heavily
loads the law implication in there.
I'm pretty sure illegal was said at some point in that conversation.
I do think somebody asked if Dan has a PI license. That was my
assumption was like Dan's probably told me on stream at some
point that he's got a PI license or something. I'm guessing he
does and that's why he thinks he's allowed to do it and nobody
else is. Cuz Dan's all in all of you I wouldn't be shocked if
Dan had whatever the highest tier that tool is. I wouldn't be
shocked if he had it. Right? Dan does this stuff all the time.
For fun. Dan will do it for fun.
Like without without the goal of harassing somebody without the
goal of like telling them he did it. He will just look >> their
name into a little service to have a little peruse while he's
sitting there, you know.
I feel like he'll pour himself a drink, sit down one night and
be like, "Hey, here's somebody who just came on stream. I wonder
what I can find about them." I fully believe he knows that. >> of
glass of whiskey or wine or something, handful of Ambien, fistful
of
>> Sit sit down at his desk. What's Nick Andrews' first
name? I shouldn't say anything about I should just like, "Okay,
yeah, just let them." Protector? No, you're not the you don't
have a license to do this. It's against the law for you to do
that. >> if it's it Ooh, there it is. It's against the
law for you to do it. Yeah, yeah. There you go. That's definitely
not true. >> You added it. Yeah, so that is not true at
all and they go to prove saying that's the only good thing Dan
said in this entire conversation. Nice one, you [__]
idiot. It's against the law. >> No. Are you kidding me?
Wait, why is it that this guy is a private and he's leaking court
documents and harassing me.
That's actually And the police said [__] Then Wait,
wait, just give me Nobody Nobody in that sub So, yeah.
It's really gay.
This is all over a woman. In every single instance. Why are we
I don't I just don't >> on weird crusades like every woman
is Helen of Troy.
What what's wrong with you? What why are you doing this?
Dude, I I just can't I I can't I can't understand. I refuse to
understand actually. And on top of all of that
you know, I don't know this as I said I don't know the specificities
of what I'm about to mention, okay, the the absolute specificities
of it all, okay? I think >> dissolved in my head. >> that
having a Discord server Oh, never >> that sole purpose
is to monitor
specific YouTubers is cringe.
It's not the sole purpose.
Clipping Discord is the it's literally for clipping. Clipping
and archiving. Clipping and archiving. So, a general content
creation. I'd say the archiving is in service of the yeah, clipping
and yeah, exactly. I I I don't Yeah, like realistically supporting
a set of content creators is really what it's about, right? The
clipping and the >> a resource pooling.
You know, user, you know,
what what would you say? It's like the sweatshop. It's a sweatshop.
In of itself, irrelevant to all the other pedantic details, irrelevant
to whether or not there was doxxing, whether or not there was
organizing harassment campaigns, whether or not there was organizing
a mass flagging, ignoring all those details, let's assume they're
all false narrative claims.
The mere act of having a Discord server that sole goal is to
monitor If he says it's gay, I'm going to actually I'm I'm messaging
him right now to hop on the >> Yeah. The day in the life
of X number of YouTubers on this on a very specific side of the
EHD drama fence
is absolute absolute peak
That's cringe and gay. Dude, it's like all of these words mean
nothing. >> all this is gay, this is cringe. It's man like
all there's nothing. You're saying nothing. I would say it's
gay to pretend you have an argument when you just don't like
the people. Just fire up your stream and go, "I really hate these
guys." Just be the whole picture gay. Don't pretend you have
an argument. Just say, "I hate everything these guys do. It's
all gay and cringe."
Go on your stream and just cry. Just gather right down crying.
If this is what you [laughter] want to
just fire up your stream and cry for me, okay? Because that's
all I'm hearing right now. [laughter] That's what you do.
And yet all these content creators were
this obsessed.
I'm going to be I'm going to be very honest with you. Uh that's
one thing we'll never deny, okay? Yep. Extremely obsessed. >> I'm
obsessed. Totally obsessed.
None of this matters.
None of this matters. None of this is actually world-ending levels
of importance.
And if you want to end up where this guy is in life at the >> two
things actually. Wait. >> Yes. Dude, nothing >> doesn't
doesn't matter or world-ending. Wait, those are actually the
It's a binary actually. I don't know this. Uh >> It's either
going to end the world or it doesn't matter.
Dude, it's If you want to end up where this guy is in life at
the age that he's at, have this attitude about everything, okay?
Actually, nothing you do matters. Never have passion or try to
get anything done cuz nothing you do matters. Just be black-pilled,
be this fat drunk loser making videos where you make no arguments
on your Saturday night, your Sunday night. Right? If that's what
you want, then keep walking through the world like nothing you
do matters. Holy [__] This is all completely removed,
irrelevant internet nonsense with very little to no real-world
impact with exception to maybe whatever doxxing occurred, which
as far as I can tell no real-world impact has happened actually
at all in the wake of most of if not any or if not all of this
doxing. But on top of that
Uh obvious corollary of people not talking about By the way,
not implying anything with this, but an obvious corollary of
not talking about your doxx would be not talking about any attempts
on any of your stuff that would have been done with a doxx, right?
So, you would never know this. You
You can just >> And again, I'll just reiterate that is
not implying anything happened. I'm not implying that. You just
wouldn't talk about it, obviously. Pull the plug. You can pull
THE PLUG AND IT GOES AWAY.
IT GOES AWAY. LIKE YOU UNPLUG YOUR COMPUTER and then magically,
all the drama just ends. Okay? Like holy What are the odds? Oh
my god. Whoa. Okay, I'm just so tired of this EHD drama. People
are acting like this is on par with a exercise meteor flying
through our atmosphere. They act like this is some world-ending
end of the world nonsense. And what sucks about this How could
you possibly be upset about Destiny getting reported for doxxing
and not lose your mind at this disgusting spineless
fantastic [__] Ethan Klein, suing people for their
content and their criticisms? How in the world could you hold
these two ideas in your head at the same time? So funny, man.
Dude, it's
>> It's It's just like he's just not thought through anything.
It's like so pathetic, bro. It's like legit like
single-celled organism like pure just, you know, stimuli
just dr- dragging him around. He's literally there is no processing
power
Uh and what really makes me angry is I defended all of these
people when I was talking to Steel 2000 in my debate. There's
a video coming up on that soon. I defended all these people saying
snarkers are important
to keeping large content creators
in check. And the reality is I stand by Yes, we all agree. >> that
take.
But when you take it this far, when you're going to the point
of creating an entire Discord server dedicated dedicated to monitoring
every little time
a person streams or every single fart that they make on a Tuesday,
right? It's
>> person I've been to is Transfirebat. That is the absolute
That is the only person who has ever who has ever documented
this to that extent.
Nothing to do with any content creator in there. None of the
content creators wanted that. It was like one content creator
and a bunch of losers cuz they're obsessed with that and no one
else wanted it. [laughter] Everyone else wanted it gone.
You'll look weird to the average person. You're you're going
to look like a freak, okay? That's That's another thing about
when you try to frame this whole thing as like some op that's
meant to affect politics. It's like, "Dude, I said it's like,
"Yes, we need to stop talking about Transfirebat. Stop talking
about Transfirebat. Please stop talking about Transfirebat. I'm
sick of Use the archive button for something other than Transfirebat,
please.
>> You've been six hot streams and we've got all these
Transfirebat streams. What the [__] is going on?"
I'm just laughing that like Destiny didn't make the top three.
No political content creator made the like true political content
creator made the top three most talked about. It was Ethan Klein,
Nick Diiorio, then Transfirebat. It's just like, "Yes, Hasan
[__] directly is telling us that in order for him
to overthrow democracy and bring about the communist utopia,
we have to keep Transfirebat down. [__] with Transfirebat.
Transfirebat must be stopped. He They will bring about the
Sorry, they will maintain liberalism. The liberal world order
cannot fall so long as Transfirebat is able to grow, okay? That's
what they needed. I've got eight months of their Discord logs
and like three months of them are like totally incomprehensible
NONSENSE ABOUT
>> DUDE, I CAN'T WAIT TILL DAN ASKED THAT ON A STREAM at
some point. What the [__] is a bus ball?
>> That's just That's just the reality. You're going to
look like a parasocial
Okay, I don't know why any of you did that. It is just so dumb.
>> Like I don't get it. I refuse to understand. Anyway,
I would like to say thank you to all of my patron supporters.
These people are all enabling this guy. He is dumb. These people
suck.
All right.